bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors comment
d'abord on explique ce taux d'abstention
record depuis 20 ans 30 % en 2017 on va
quand même rappeler que aux dernières
législatives
le taux de participation a dépassé les
35 % en 2012 42% soit baba sacko comment
expliquer cette situation
alors grâce monde explique cette
situation de toute façon le loto qui est
donnée ne pas n'est pas le poids réel le
taux de participation je vais pas
m'étendre sur les formules mathématiques
utilisés par le gouvernement algérien
pour sortir ce taux de 30%
par contre ce qui est important de
savoir c'est que cette abstention
elle est là elle est réelle et elle
existe de plus en plus parce que nous
avons une combinaison de deux facteurs
1 c'est celui de la méfiance vis-à-vis
de ce pouvoir et qui a aujourd'hui fait
que c'est rédhibitoire on n'attend plus
rien les élections et puis deuxièmement
nous avons le chirac qui lui s'est
exprimé et s'est exprimée par le boycott
et c'est sa victoire et ce n'est la
victoire de personne d'autre aujourd'hui
kader abderrahim est ce que vous
partagez cet avis est ce que justement
c'est taux de participation bon cd sont
des chiffres 1 comme le dit madame bâ
vice à apprendre peut-être avec des
pincettes mais ce que cela signifie en
fait un échec du pouvoir une victoire
pour le irak
écoutez le chiffre colonne ou d'annoncés
par une information c'est une indication
dans la mesure où les impossible aux des
observateurs indépendants de vérifier
mais tous les témoignages que l'on m'a
de huy hier montre et prouve que les
bureaux de vote était totalement désert
et comme le disait un instant votre
oreille dans son reportage est l idée d
abstention record en kabylie notamment
qu une région très importante lui a
quasiment pas de participation
si ce n'est moins un sens c'est dire
leur rejet massif de la population par
rapport à ce régime mais également la
défiance sur la question de
l'organisation des élections
mais pour autant je crois que ce ne sera
pas suffisant pour faire tomber ce
régime est ce que le président avait
lui-même l'a annoncé hier en disant que
peut lui n'importe
le taux de participation est là on peut
s'interroger quelle est la légitimité
d'un exécutif qui ne tire pas sa source
du peuple c'est vrai que l'actuel
président a affirmé que pour lui le taux
de participation n'avait pas
d'importance qui importe selon lui ce
que ceux pour lesquels le peuple vote
est une légitimité suffisante comment
vous vous interpréter ces propos soit
baas à eybens nm chez nous sommes face à
déjà nous avons eu tous les algériens
ont le droit pas scrutin et trois
scrutins qui ont été rejetées que ce
soit celui qui est désigné le président
de la république puisqu'il n'a aucune
légitimité qu il a été rejeté par le
peuple algérien
le deuxième scrutin celui du référendum
a été rejetée aussi est un président
illégitime continue dans sa 2 dans son
illégitimité à dire moi je me fiche de
ce scrutin
et je me fiche de comment s'expriment
les algériens et des algériennes
tu vois ce qui m'importe c'est que je
suis là je suis placé et admin ce que
pourra je suis le représentant d'une
case pas pouvoir militaro financier et
d'une oligarchie et ce qui n'apporte
c'est de préserver leurs intérêts ce
qu'il peut arriver au peuple algérien
ils s'en fichent largement est d'abord
il s'est de plus que derrière il a le
soutien de toutes les démocraties ont
des dirigeants des démocraties
occidentales qui le maintiennent ils lui
donnent de là
légitimité puisqu'il avait besoin
aujourd'hui en faisant croire à la mise
en place d'élections législatives et
prochainement il va encore appelé les
algériens à tout en se fichant des
scrutins et de continuer dans la
mascarade a aussi appelé aux élections
municipales dont il dit pas je suis là
et le régiment ggg un warm roy keane et
absolue et qui est donnée par la caste
militaire et qui est cautionnée par les
démocraties occidentales
est ce que réclame le peuple il ne veut
pas l'entendre voilà ce qu'il faut comme
premières conclusions
donc ça veut dire quoi kader abderrahim
des élections finalement pour rien
puisque le président abdelmajid teboul
avait fait en sorte que ces élections
législatives anticipées lieu pour
justement tenter de désamorcer la
contestation en algérie j'ai pas entendu
le début de votre caisse donc je disais
des élections finalement pour rien ou
pas parce que l'on sait que le président
abdelmajid tebboune avait fait en sorte
que ces élections ces législatives
anticipées lieux pour tenter de
désamorcer la contestation
oui pas seulement désamorcer la
contestation
mais tenter de se donner un vernis de
légitimité pour continuer à gouverner
dans le sens qui lui convient je crois
que ces élections n'ont qu'un seul
objectif et poursuivre un seul but c'est
de tenter de respecter le calendrier
électoral et le messager l'état knees et
externes
il s'agit pour les partenaires de
l'algérie d'utiliser l'organisation des
élections comme un vernis représentatif
ou un vernis consultative mais qui n'a
aucune valeur aucun sens dans la mesure
où l'on voit que le rejet tant la
société algérienne est massif et que la
défiance sur l'organisation des
élections est elle aussi massif
vous parlez vous parlez tous les deux
finalement d'un roger du pouvoir d'un
désaveu des partis traditionnels mais
que dire sur la pléthore finalement deux
partis en lice plus de 1000 formation
indépendante
est ce que ce n'est pas trop pour les
électeurs mais ça pourrait aussi
peut-être expliquer ce taux d'abstention
oh que non les algériennes et les
algériens ne sont pas dupes de la
mascarade électorale et des 1700
candidats et candidates vraiment comme
vient de le dire
intel qui adhèrent d'anarchie vraiment
c'est juste du vernis il a besoin de
s'asseoir sur une légitimité et il a été
ils ont été capables d'aller chercher
dans toutes les poubelles de l'algérie
pour tenter de sortir des candidats et
des candidates excusez moi du terme mais
c'est un peu ça et il y en a qui
peut-être par naïveté je veux encore
croire que certains est une naïveté au
nom de l'amour qu'il porte pour
l'algérie certains partis politiques
soit entrée dans cette valse de jeu mais
en réalité nous sommes face à des
participants qui sont là pour faire
caisse de résonance on va leur demander
d'être simplement une caisse
d'enregistrement et quand ils sont à la
sortie ils ont le bout d'encaissement
voilà ce qu'il faudrait comment est-ce
qu'il faut sacrément maintenant à un
durcissement est ce qu'il faut
s'attendre maintenant un durcissement
justement de du mouvement de la
contestation est ce que ces élections
c'est une justice mans il est intenable
est ce que ces élections montrent que
finalement le que le irak creuse un peu
plus son sillon le rac a appelé au
boycott avec l'opposition cadart
appareils il est clair qu'aujourd'hui si
il y à un gagnant c'est le peuple
algérien celle qui est des qui depuis
deux ans et demi
manifeste au moins deux fois par semaine
de façon pacifique et les hommages qui
au début de ses lattes de cette grande
mobilisation populaire
à travers toute l'algérie on plus sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup discret et je crois
que les démocrates en europe notamment
des singulièrement en france devrait
soutenir ce mouvement qui va dans le
sens de celui de la constitution d'un
état de droit et de la tentative de la
tentation de construire de parvenir à
une démocratie réelle et non plus formel
comme celle à laquelle on a assisté avec
cette mascarade d'élection donc le
durcissement pour le moment il est du
côté du régime
et ça fait au moins vingt ans que les
observateurs n'ont pas vécu une telle
situation
imaginez que la veille du scrutin on a
arrêté deux journalistes très en vue
ainsi qu'un dirigeant politique elle une
table ou simplement simplement parce que
il s'agissait d'envoyer un message une
menace pour parler de manière très
directe et rigal au reste de la société
afin qu'elles comprennent bien
qu'aujourd'hui le régime ne tolère
aucune voix dissonante et discordants
3,3 figure de girac arrêtés dont un
journaliste elles ont été libérées
vous pensez que ces arrestations plus de
200 personnes selon le comité national
pour la libération des détenus en serai
frais
un corps en état d'arrestation en
détention est ce que vous pensez
sow agba valls que cela va continuer ces
arrestations mais les arrestations
outils bureau jour d'hui on en est à des
enlèvements légal et ce en quoi
j'appelle aussi des instances
internationales
c'est ce qui vient d'être et le code
pénal a été modifié il y a deux jours et
ce code pénal il est clair qu'il a
changé la donne puisqu'il a introduit un
article 87 bis qui déclare que toute
personne aujourd'hui qui amènerait à
être qu'ils appelleraient à changer le
système de gouvernance par des moyens
non constitutionnels porte atteinte à
l'intégrité du territoire national et
qui l'inciterait à le faire par quelques
moyens que ce soit dont pourrait être
arrêté et donc on est vraiment comme
vient de le dire avec cadalen gym quand
les trois journalistes ont été arrêtés
ce n'est pas de l'arrestation c'est de
l' enlèvement légal et ça se durcit il y
à 226 détenus dont 80 qui sont en grève
de la faim ou pas une dernière question
importante
désolé faut interroger le dernière
question importante puisque le parti
l'un des principaux partis islamistes un
le mouvement de la société pour la paix
de mouvements islamistes affirme qu'il a
remporté justement
ces législatives alors qu'on n'a pas
encore les résultats officiels devraient
intervenir dans quelques jours
que faut-il penser de ces de cette
déclaration et kader abderrahim écouter
ils sont cons saurions tout droit vers
une chambre dans laquelle il n'y aura
pas de majorité
et cela permettra à l'exécutif algérien
au pouvoir réel pas celui incarné par le
président de bonne de gouverner comme il
l'entend et de prendre les décisions qui
lui conviennent je crois qu'il est
important de souligner que dans le fond
l'obsession de ce régime politique c'est
la pérennité du système tel qu'il existe
depuis l'indépendance en 1962
même si là il a vécu quelques
changements à la marge il là il a
toujours été ce qu'il est mais
probablement aujourd'hui plus dur et
plus virulent que jamais contre la
société
donc évidemment sans souhaiter que l'on
aille vers une confrontation
il y aura forcément un moment où la
société viendra se révolter contre
l'arbitraire et contre l'absence de
liberté et les islamistes sont
aujourd'hui les garants de la pérennité
du système
il ne représente plus une opposition
quelle qu'elle soit la preuve la preuve
aujourd'hui ce soir ils s'arrogent déjà
l'élection la victoire alors je sais pas
peut-être que le msp sera le premier
parti représenté à l'assemblée mais ça
signifie pas pour autant qu'il aura une
majorité pour faire comme ils l'ont vous
êtes d'accord
tapas et sarthe ont fermé le clapet mois
pour moi il n'ya qu'un seul gagnant à
céret
à ce scrutin c'est le fait de toujours
que ce peuple algérien les algériens et
les algériennes considère que ce pouvoir
est illégitime et qu'il pleurait un
changement radical et je continuerai
autant de cadalen times il faut vraiment
que les dirigeants d'eads et des
démocraties occidentales que les
démocrates qui vivent dans les autres
pays soutiennent le peuple algérien il
en va de l'intérêt des jeunes
merci pour cette conclusion soit baysa
remercie et je rappelle que vous êtes
militante féministe et merci à vous
kader abderrahim directeur de recherche
à l'ipp sauf un